♪ (chant traditionnel) ♪
- Manuel Mathieu, vous êtes
une des vedettes du monde
de l'art contemporain. On se
trouve dans votre nouvelle
exposition sur la mélancolie.
Qu'est-ce que vous v
exprimer avec toutes ces formes,
tous ces mouvements?
MANUEL MATHIEU,
artiste visuel
- Bien... bon, ces mouveme
et ces formes-là reflètent mon
esprit, déjà. On va commencer
par ça. Et je cherche...
je sais pas, je me considère
comme un chercheur qui tombe
sur des choses et qui les ramène
dans notre réalité en fait.
- Votre histoire est vraiment
fascinanrcrcrcrce que vous êtes
né en Haïti, puis à 15 ans votre
oncle vous a inité à l'art.
- Oui, oui.
- À 19 ans, vous êtes débarqué à
Montréal. C'est votre grand-mère
qui a vécu sous le régime
de Jean-Claude Duvalier...
- Oui, oui.
- Et c'est elle qui vous a
encouragé d'une certaine façon,
parce que c'est pas ce que
vos parents voulaient, là.
- Oui, bien... j'étais...
tu vois, il faut comprendre
que j'étais un enfant difficile)
Puis difficile, je veux dire,
tu sais, je veux pas vous
donner de détails, là,
mais j'étais un adolescent
très adolesonononon va dire.
Donc, mes parents, ils avaient
peur. En fait, ils ne me
contrôlaient plus mes parents.
Donc, jejejeje suis arrivé ici
puis j'ai laissé Haïti,
c'était comme un soulagement
pour eux. Et quand je suis
arrivé, mamamama grand-mère
était là pour nous recevoir
plusieurs... plusieurs...
ma soeur était déjà là,
je pense, avec mon cousin.
Donc, c'est e e e e contexte-là,
elle, elle ne m'a pas posé
de questions, en fait.
m m m m'a juste supporté
dans qui je voulais devenir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Comment un adolescent
difficile réussit à faire
une maîtrise à Londres...
- Oui.
-... et avoir un succè
qu'il connaît aujourd'hui?
- Bien, c'est que l'adolescent
a arrêté d'être un adolescent.
Il est devenu un homme
qui a vécu des choses,
qui a certainement cassé
des oeufs sur son chemin,
mais qui a évolué et qui
est devenu quelqu'un de...
pas dire raisonnable,
mais quelqu'un qui a...
qui a un rêve.
- Il y a un événement
qui a vraiment changé
votre pratique artistique,
c'est cet accident de moto.
- Oui.
- Il y a un délit de fuite
dans cette affaire-là.
Vous avez presque perdu la vie.
- Oui.
- Comment ça s'est passé
pour vous ce changement-là,
parce que vous vous êtes mis à
vous intéresser à la solitude
par la suite, aussi à l'amnésie.
- Oui, oui, oui, oui.
Ma grand-mère était
en train de mourir
à la même époque d'un cancer,
donc ça m'a do p p p petit peu
du... ça m'a permis de me
rapprocher d'elle, déjà,
parce que j'étais en train de...
pendant qu'elle était en train
de disparaître, moi,
j'étais en train de
reprendre possession
de mon esprit en fait.
Et ça m'a fait me poser
des questions sur son histoire
à elle, sur l'histoire de
mon pays, sur l'histoire d
sur la question que je me posais
mais que j'avais pas de réponse.
Comme, pourquoi est-ce que j'ai
popopoposé à autant de violence
en grandissant en Haïti?
Puis, j'ai compris qu'on était,
ma génération, la première
génération qui sort de la
dictature. Moi, j'ai 35 ans,
je suis né en 86, c'est la date
de la fin de la dictature.
Donc, on est la première
génération de jeunes de 30 ans
et plus qui... d'adultes,
en fait. Donc, c'est dans ce
contexte-là que je me suis dit :
Bien, je veux travailler
là-dessus.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Manuel Mathieu,
expliquez-moi votre ascension,
parce que vous avez 35 ans,
mais en très peu de temps,
vous êtes vraiment devenu
dedededette dans le monde
de l'art contemporain
et vous vendez beaucoup
de toiles à plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de dollars.
Avez-vous l'impressionde vivre ?
Parce qu'il y a très peu
d'artistes en arts visuels
contemporains qui réussissent
comme vous réussissez.
- Je suis d'accord.
Je ne dirai pas que
c'est un conte de fées.
Je pense que...
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
C'est titititivement
un rodéo si on veut,
parce que c'est foisonnant,
c'est aussi nouveau,
parce qu'on a... tu sais,
on parle de mon succès
comme si j'étais totalement
en contrôle de ce qui se passe,
mais c'est beaucoup de
nouveautés par exemple,
parce qu'au fur et à mesure
que les gens commencen
à s'habituer à qui je suis
en tant que peintre,
en tant qu'artiste,
moi, je suis en train
de me multiplier
dans d'autreinininines.
Donc, je suis toujours...
on parlait d'adolescence
tout à l'heure,
je suis toujours dans
un espace de nouveauté,
de régénérescence,
qui fait que je ne...
peut-être que je ne réalise pas
que c'est un conte de fées.
- En temps que Montréalais,
vous devez être fier,
parce que vous avez été choisi
pour créer cinq mosaïques pour
le Réseau express métropolitain.
- Oui, le REM!
(rire)
Quelle nouvelle!
Écoutez, ça... c'est...cette not
inimaginable pour moi,
parce que moi, quand
je suis arrivé ici,
j'étais à Blainville,
puis j'ai étudié au HEC.
J'allais au HEC pour étudier,
donc c'est la statioù je m'arrê,
Édouard-Montpetit
ou Université-de-Montréal.
Pour moi, c'était inimaginable,.
d'avoir un impact aussi énorme
dans la société qui
m'a vu grandir, c'est...
c'était inimaginable.
C'est pour ça que je suis
très content et reconnaissant.
- Manuel Mathieu, vous devez me
quitter parce que vous partez
pour la France pour six mois.
- Oui.
- Bon voyage,
merci pour l'entrevue.
- Merci. Ça fait plaisir.
♪ ♪ ♪